members of Grace Presbyterian Church off
the I-15 in Charleston say Nevada is the
largest and most expensive public works
project has left them almost
inaccessible and struggling for
donations Ryan mathey joins us live to
explain their dilemma Ryan
yeah Kirsten Christian even we can
attest to some of these struggles we had
quite the time trying to find this
location and the big reason why this is
such a problem is this overpass right
over here it was built as part of the
neon project in 2018 now church members
say people cannot find a way inside it
means less money for good deeds and
their new location
so we lost the ability for a year to
worship and then when we came back
people couldn't find the property
nowadays Senior Pastor Jim Houston
hankin says these seats inside the Grace
Presbyterian Church sit mostly empty we
would average Maybe
10 12 visitors from the strip from out
of town who would come and join us for
worship on Sundays
that is completely dried up the reason
project neon he says the state's largest
and most expensive public works project
to date one billion dollars used to
enhance four miles of Interstate 15
Nevada's busiest stretch of highway you
can't even see the property even from
the freeway but the construction did not
enhance the church once five entrances
down to two both only one way with no
legal turnaround for roughly a mile from
either one once we had a funeral
here and the hearse could not find an
entrance to the church and showed up 30
minutes late
there's just nothing you can do to make
that right and with less visitors
willing to navigate the property less
donations during service that would go
to Ministries like feeding the hungry in
2018 the church sued the state saying
utilities were forced underneath Church
property against the landowner's will
that case now settled the church
receiving an undisclosed amount of money
to move to this new property on Durango
and Oquendo but it's still not enough
three to four million dollars short of
mirroring what they had here here so
it's difficult when we have to take
money that would have been used for
for Ministries like feeding the hungry
and so forth
now they're doing those fundraising
efforts on their website you can find
out more about it on our website and
regardless if those extra millions are
actually fundraised they plan to begin
constructing what they can afford this
spring reporting live from the Grace
Presbyterian Church Ryan Matthey 8 News
Now